i know so many people struggling deeply
with fertility issues does that trace
back i know you talked about the
endocrine disruptors and you know we did
a whole long list today of not only
buried you know emotions but we started
with chemical toxins and food and nature
and the blue light and all of that do
you feel that that's impacting
significantly the fertility rates in the
country and why everyone's now turning
to ivf and there's a lot of just
hopelessness and desperation around
fertility right now
yeah i think um
i think the number one reason why
there's so many fertility issues is
toxic load i think most of us
are suffering with environmental toxins
at a high level
and it's affecting our reproductive
system
you have to understand for these
environmental chemicals
it is hormonal immune neurological and
reproductive those are the systems that
are most affected uh and i would say
probably hormonal and reproductive being
the number one
um
if you think about it there's so many
hormone disruptors that i mean hormones
are essential
for
for getting pregnant hormones are
essential for a healthy
successful pregnancy even before that
hormones are essential for a healthy
sperm in men right and we know
that so many of these chemicals and i
did a whole show
talking about
how these chemicals there's a there's a
list i listed all the chemicals that are
really affecting sperm quality not only
not only the the the motility of the
sperm but even just the count the
concentration we don't even have enough
sperm as men and a lot of these
chemicals that are found in these
pesticides and herbicides or or remember
we were talking about off gas chemicals
those volatile chemicals
a lot of them
are found in in a lot and a lot of these
things that we're being exposed to they
saw that atrazine a chemical that is
found in a lot of our food was
feminizing
frogs right in these lakes right this
was a study out of berkeley it was
incredible to see that the increase in
feminization the reduction in
testosterone right
one of the major things is these
environmental toxins same thing with
women disrupting estrogen disrupting
progesterone increasing testosterone
right these are big big big issues
anyone who's looking to get pregnant or
anyone who has an unsuccessful pregnancy
or a
any actually i would say
i'll go back and say anyone that he's
even looking to get pregnant from the
beginning
you've got to go to a functional doctor
gotta go to a naturopathic doctor run
your environmental toxin test right look
at your heavy metals look at your
pesticides look at your herbicides just
see the list of chemicals ask them for
it they can do it in your pee and we can
see
okay whoa
i had no idea that
we're living or
being dry cleaning my clothes all the
time using bpa not eating organic i
didn't have i didn't know that this had
this was surmounting to this
manifestation when you see it on paper
know that that is going to be your
number one obstacle to having a healthy
pregnancy right so
very very important get your
environmental toxic load tested from a
naturopathic or functional doctor before
you get pregnant a lot of people can
just get pregnant and awesome great but
if you have at least one unsuccessful
pregnancy you already know that's the
number one thing you need to look at if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]